the filmmakers responsible for the mcu
knew thanos was coming long before we
did there are moments throughout
marvel's movies that go by in the blink
of an eye but are actually very
important to the big picture
we just didn't know it yet here's your
spoilers ahead warning
we are saying what's important to
endgame we think but we aren't spoiling
specific plot points to end game
we're just using the clues from past
films so you're safe
unless we're right about everything and
if so
oops it's an easy thing to forget
behind his high-tech armor and sarcastic
facade tony stark
is still only human he's not physically
the strongest of the avengers
but stark certainly has the strongest
personality
security breach is on you mr stark phil
come in phil i can't stay
his first name is agent tony stark's
plucky personality makes it easy to
forget that he's ultimately fallible
rather than being all wit and one-liners
tony struggles with a feeling of
powerlessness
after the battle of new york and it's a
feeling that we would never have
associated with such a powerful figure
in iron man 3 tony has flashbacks to the
black maw of the wormhole that he never
thought he'd come out of
his knowledge of the reality of what's
out there in space especially
civilizations with bigger batter weapons
haunts him plaguing him with ptsd
flashbacks and nightmares
in avengers age of ultron this fear of
the danger lurking in space
manifests in the nightmarish
hallucinations that scarlet witch
subjects him to
tony sees black widow cab thor all of
his friends
broken and dead
you could've saved us
in a way this turns out to be a vision
of the future
in infinity war as hard as he tries tony
is unable to stop thanos from getting
the final infinity stone needed for the
big snap
he watches in horror as his friends fall
around him
while he stands powerless we probably
can't convince you to watch thor the
dark world if you haven't already
and if you have watched it a single
viewing is probably enough
the plot is a tangled web and thor is
honestly kind of insufferable
at least pretend to enjoy yourself but
while the dark world is among the
weakest entries in the marvel cinematic
universe the movie
does a phenomenal job of introducing the
nature of the infinity stones and
teasing their future importance
thor and his girlfriend dr jane foster
are thrown into an age-old conflict
between
asgard and the dark elves long ago the
elves had sought to conquer the nine
realms with the power of the ether
a red tinged force created from the
reality stone
it was sealed away by odin's own father
but it was unleashed when the nine
realms aligned
then it infected jane they're only able
to destroy the ether when it's fused
with malakith the leader of the dark
elves
but the reality stone remains in a
post-credit scene it's officially called
an
infinity stone the tesseract is already
on asgard it is not wise to keep two
infinity stones so close together
because asgard is already guarding the
space stone they send the reality stone
to the collector
who we find out has his own goal of
collecting them all
being a superhero isn't your average
nine to five you have to fight bad guys
all over the world
face down death on countless occasions
and deal with overpowered co-workers who
have anger issues
we're looking at you hulk keeping all
that in mind
there's a good reason why the avengers
aren't really the sort of people to
settle down and start families
except of course for hawkeye clint
barton lives a double life
out in the world he's a deadly archer
and agent of shield
but at home he's a husband and father in
avengers age of ultron
clint surprised everyone by taking them
to his homestead and safe house where
his wife and kids live
that's where he was holed up under house
arrest during the events of infinity war
which explains his notable absence from
the film's posters
now do you know what a chekhov's gun is
basically if a gun appears in act 1
someone should get shot in act 2. well
there's a reason clint's family was
all smiles in age of ultron and every
trailer for end game showed an
angry ronin-style clint barton do the
math
wakanda may be an isolated nation that
hides its secrets from the world but
that doesn't mean we hadn't heard about
it before black panther
wakanda previously refused aid from
other countries and its people rarely
venture outside of its borders
that's why it's a huge international
incident when civilians
including wakandan scientists on a
goodwill mission are killed in the
crossfire between the avengers and
crossbones
terrorist crew at the beginning of
captain america civil war
our people's blood is spilled on foreign
soil
captain america's shield is made from
the strongest material in the world
vibranium as a former weapons
manufacturer tony stark is well aware
that wakanda
is the only one place you can get
vibranium it's highly valued on the
black market where disreputable arms
dealers like ulysses claw operate
we meet claude just before he loses an
arm during an encounter with ultron
in age of ultron when we see him again
in black panther he's replaced the
appendage with a robotic prosthesis
which makes him all the more dangerous
or at least more badass
the mcu was packed with references to
wakanda long before
we ever saw the place for ourselves in
black panther
tony stark and steve rogers don't always
get along
in fact it's their disagreements that
ultimately tear the avengers in two
you've been busy and you've been a
complete idiot but that doesn't mean
they're not friends
and friends always have each other's
best interests at heart
during the events of captain america
civil war that's what divides iron man
and captain america
each man thinks he knows what's right
for their super powered friends
fast forward to the end of the movie
after they've been able to punch the
ever loving heck out of one another and
feel a little better
despite their many differences they
still support one another
tony receives a package and inside is a
cell phone and a letter which reads in
part
we all need family the avengers are
yours
maybe more so than mine it's the line
about family that weighs heavily on
tony's future
the post credit scene shows a young
peter parker experimenting with web
shooters
and in the following films we see that
spider-man is something of an adopted
son to tony
cap's words resonate even further
considering the conversation tony and
pepper have in infinity war
last night i dreamt we had a kid
so real we all need family right
after the big snap and after countless
worlds start crumbling into dust
the mad titan himself is taken to a
red-tinged plane where nothing exists
save for a familiar looking arch and the
silhouette of a little girl
it's gamora the same young gamora that
thanos met when he killed half the
people on her planet
she asks him what his victory cost not
looking the least bit triumphant thanos
grimly replies
everything but what does that mean
of course the scene emphasizes the fact
that thanos really did love gamora but
the moment is about more than mere
reminiscence
in order to get the soul stone thanos
had to sacrifice the soul of somebody he
loved
he sacrificed gamora and her soul was
claimed by the stone
with the power of the infinity stones
thanos wiped out
exactly half the population of the whole
universe
all those souls have to go somewhere in
the marvel universe anyway
they go to the soul world a pocket
dimension in the soul stone itself
so gamora is in the soul stone that's
what it meant right
that might be important later when the
first thor film was released in 2011
magic still wasn't a part of the marvel
cinematic universe
only science sure tony stark made a
flying metal suit and an artificial
intelligence so smart that it could
backtalk
but that wasn't actual magic just good
old-fashioned engineering
well thor changed all that sort of in a
rather romantic scene with dr jane
foster thor explains that what people
call
magic is the same thing as science back
where he comes from
norse mythology interprets the nine
realms as branches of the world tree
yggdrasil but we would think of them as
planets
the rainbow bridge bifrost creates
wormholes in which asgardians travel
and asgardians aren't gods they're a
superpowered race of aliens who just so
happen to look a lot like humans we
didn't know it back then
but this explanation paves the way for
other planets and other civilizations to
come into play in the mcu
asgardians were the first alien species
introduced in the mcu
but later films would add the chatari
the kree and the skrulls
to name but a few in some form the
tesseract has shown up in a number of
marvel films
serving as the macguffin in not one but
three movies
in captain america we learned that it
was originally brought to earth by
asgard only to be stolen by nazis and
hydra
in captain marvel it was given to
project pegasus by howard stark with the
goal of making a light speed engine
it was stolen by loki in the avengers
only to be taken back to asgard and
stolen again by loki in thor ragnarok
but another infinity stone had been
hiding in plain sight
loki's scepter is special for a reason
and it's not just because it's the
season's must-have accessory that
perfectly matches his horned helmet
gifted to loki by thanos the scepter
isn't just any old alien weapon
it actually contains the mine stone
which is why it can be used for mind
control and general evil doing
once loki is carted away in chains to
asgard
shield studies the scepter and is able
to discern that it had some kind of
connection to the tesseract
then it's stolen by hydra and used to
give powers to test subjects like
scarlet witch and quicksilver
when the avengers get their hands on it
again tony stark and bruce banner
discovered that within the scepter
something is thinking i mean this could
be
it's not a human mind i mean look at
this
yes it's the mind stone which is then
used to create vision
in order to keep the power away from
ultron got that
good let's not forget how important the
guardians of the galaxy series has been
in tying together the plot line of the
infinity stones
despite taking place far far away from
earth the films have introduced key
players and background in the struggle
for the stones
what's also important to note is that
guardians of the galaxy vol 2
may have introduced the most powerful
character in the whole
mcu nope we're not talking about ego
his power pales in comparison to the
mighty force cocooned in golden pipes by
the sovereign
the second guardians of the galaxy film
starts with rocket doing what he does
best
stealing and stealing batteries no less
what were you thinking dude they were
really easy to steal that's your defense
come on
this draws the wrath of the sovereign
who make it their mission to destroy the
guardians
failing to do so by more conventional
means prompts the sovereign leader high
priestess aisha to create a new weapon
a new being more powerful more beautiful
and more capable of destroying the
guardians
she decides to name it adam and comic
readers already know
adam warlock is one of the most powerful
characters in marvel's comics
rocket's sticky fingers may have led to
the creation of the most
powerful being in the universe
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you